Attorney General bar denied yesterday
that the special counsel intended to let
Congress decide the unresolved issue of
obstruction but the Moller report
clearly acknowledges lawmakers have the
authority to determine whether the
president's actions represent an
obstruction of justice House Judiciary
Committee Chairman Jerry Nadler is
expected to issue a subpoena for the
full report including details removed by
the Justice Department under the law
along with all underlying materials
collected in the investigation Attorney
General bar appears to have shown an
unsettling willingness to undermine his
own department in order to protect
president Trump Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with more Nancy good
morning a good morning in Congress or at
least a few key members will get a look
at a lot of that sensitive redacted
material next week because the
Department of Justice is going to
provide key congressional leaders with
access to that sensitive information in
special secure reading rooms here on
Capitol Hill and Democrats are now
vowing to pick up where Muller left off
they say that he gave them a road map of
sorts to pursue their own obstruction of
justice investigation here's what Muller
said on page 8 of the report this is
what they're pointing to quote we
concluded that Congress has authority to
prohibit a president's corrupt use of
his authority in order to protect the
integrity of the administration of
justice Democrats are also sounding off
on Attorney General Barr who they say
quote deliberately distorted significant
portions of special counsel Muller's
report while Republicans on the other
hand say that the bottom line is no
collusion it's time to move on but
frankly here on Capitol Hill it is going
to be hard to move on there are already
multiple congressional committees
calling on robert muller to testify here
on Capitol Hill and Barr himself is
going to get grilled about his choices
in early May Gale all right Nancy thank
you very much